- Comme bien d'autres pistes
cyclables à Montréal,
celle de la rue Villeray
s'arrête abruptement.
Elle sera prolongée de 5 km
supplémentaire bien accueillie
par les cyclistes
dans le secteur.
- J'aime pas trop circuler
sans piste cyclable.on avec
les voitures. Il y a les gens
ent de l'espace,
il y a des gens qui donnent
pas d'espace.réal va laréal va r
une quarantaine de projets cetts
cyclables ou en aménager
de nouvelles.s totalisent
près de 36 km, un investissemen.
MARIANNE GIGUÈRE, conseillèreasl
à consolider, à,
toujours pour rendre la pratique
du vélo plus attirante.
- Un premier tronçon du Réseau
son apparition sur le boulevard
Henri-Bourassa dans
l'arrondissement St-Laurent.
ville, dans l'axe Viger,
St-Antoiues.
Vélo Québec salue la volonté
de la Ville, mais estime
pour atteindre son objectif
de doubler la tailer la tailer u
cyclable.
JEAN-FRANÇOIS RHEAULT
- Il faut aller plus vite.
Au rythme actuel, ça prendra
40 ans pour achever le plan
vélo.
- On est très dé
- Vélo fantôme s'inquiète pour
la sécurité des cylors
que sept d'entre eux sont morts
lors d'accident à Montréal
l'an der
Vélo fantôme
- Oui, iuriser
les intersections, mais
c'est qu'il manque des pistes
unidirecute.
- Des fois, je roule sur
ou genre De Lorimier
qu'il y a pas de piste cyclable
du tout, puis t'as toujours
tout le tout le tout le tout lei
va te rentrer dedans.- D'autresi
y allaient avec beaucoup plus
de kilomètres, mais c'était
la chaussée. Nous, on fait
vraiment des projets de qualité.
- Par ailleurs, la Ville aura
a l'oeil les automobilistes qui
se stationnent dans les pistes
cyclables. Des agents
patrouilleront sur le Réseau
express vélo de la rue St-Denis
pilote.
SOPHIE MAUZEROLLE, responsab
de la mobilité, Montréal
- Ils vont circuler eux-mêmes
à vélo sur la pis
remorquer au besoin, donner
des contraventions
- La Ville souhaite étendre
cette initiative à l'ensemble
des pist
Ici Olivier Bachand,